-Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here. Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, here's some much-needed good news.
Beyoncé just announced that next month
she's releasing a new album called "Renaissance."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then everyone else releasing an album was like,
"Okay, August it is. Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
This will be Beyoncé's first album since 2016.
Come on. That's too long. That's too long.
In that same time,
Taylor Swift's released 42 albums.
I mean, come on.
Of course, fans are pumped for the album.
Seriously, the only thing going more platinum
is Ryan Gosling as Ken. You know?
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. That's right.
This is big news for the music business
and even bigger news for the wind-machine industry.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this.
Today, for the first time, Elon Musk met virtually
with Twitter employees at a company-wide meeting.
[ Audience oohs ] Ooh.
Employees called it good practice
for that awkward phone call with Dad on Father's Day.
Yeah, picture the awkwardness of a Zoom happy hour
times 44 billion. You know what I'm saying?
Some more business news --
I heard that Facebook is planning a major redesign
on its main feed to help it compete with TikTok.
[ Audience oohs ] When people accused them
of copying TikTok, Facebook said,
"We're not copying TikTok. We're duetting with TikTok."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, did you guys see this?
A British Airways flight got a little hectic
when water started flooding from the ceiling
while the plane was in air.
Look at this. This is scary.
-Ohh.
-Yeah. At that point, the pilot was like,
"Uh, tonight's in-flight entertainment
is anyone who wants to re-enact that scene from 'The Notebook.'
You can just...go for it."
But everyone just made the best of it.
They just turned the inflatable chute
into a Slip 'N Slide.
It was fun. It was fun.
I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did a stand-up.
I was doing a stand-up Slip 'N Slide.
-Yeah, I saw that. It was like --
More like a Slip 'N -- like Surf 'N Slide.
-Yeah, well, I mean, that's what you do
at the advanced level.
'Cause obviously you do the belly flop and go --
slide right down, but then you get muddy and all that stuff,
and then by the end of the afternoon,
you get bored and you go, "Let me try this."
-So you do it up. You do it standing up.
Yeah.
♪♪
-Look out, look out, look out!
Wipeout!
[ Steve imitating "Wipeout" giggle ]
-What? Wha--
-That was the "Wipeout"...
-Of course. -Yeah.
-Uh, hey, guys, I saw that Disney is offering
a new high-end travel package
called Disney Parks Around the World,
where you travel on a private jet
to all their parks for $110,000.
[ Audience ohhs ]
But they're not the only theme park
offering a deluxe package, though.
No. Watch this.
-Can't afford Disney's Around the World tickets?
Then book your spot on the Busch Gardens VIP Tour.
[ Coughing ]
For just $65.99, you'll get to climb aboard
this magical chariot... [ Horn honking ]
...while enjoying the finest of beverages...
and sampling the freshest foods as you're chauffeured
between the London and Paris of America,
Virginia and Tampa.
[ Clearing throat ]
When you see what looks like an abandoned
haunted amusement park, you've arrived.
The Busch Gardens VIP Tour.
Make sure you got your tetanus shot!
-Wow. That was...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, guys, with summer movie season here,
there's tons of great stuff in theaters right now,
so I wanted to run down
everything worth seeing in a new segment.
It's time for "The Tonight Show Hollywood Pop Corner."
Here we go.
-♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ The Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're in "Hollywood Pop Corner."
Let's roll picture.
"Lightyear."
You won't need a light beer to enjoy "Lightyear."
In fact, the only buzz I got was from actor Chris Evans,
who'll have audiences in bliss heavens.
Should you see it? I Holly would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Elvis." He's left the building,
but he's shimmying back into theaters everywhere.
Austin Butler's performance had this critic all shook up.
And I, for one, smell a hunk of, hunk of
burning up the box office.
Should you see it? I Holly would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Jurassic World: Dominion."
No, not "da Minions," those little yellow scamps.
But there's plenty of mischief in this world,
caused by all the bloodthirsty dinosaurs running amok.
Should man play God? Probably not.
Should you see it? I Holly would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Top Gun: Maverick."
Tom Cruise may be leavin' on a jet plane,
but it's audiences who'll be back again and again
to see the sequel with all the right stuff.
Top Gun? More like top-notch entertainment.
Permission to be thrilled? Aye-aye Holly would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Bad Guys."
More like "The Great Family Film."
This movie's filled with heart, laughs, and style to spare.
To quote another "bad guy," duh, Billy I Holly would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Morbius."
♪ Morb, morb, morb ♪
♪ How do you like it, how do you like it? ♪
I love this tale of the Dracula doctor
with the heart of an Oscar gold.
Should you see it? Your call. I'm not your boss.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. [ Laughs ]
Well, the corn...
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
Corn's getting cold, which means it's time
to roll credits on "The Pop Corner."
Remember to silence your cellphones.
I'll see you at the claw machine in the lobby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ The Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
-Wow.
How much popcorn --
I ate one piece of popcorn.
-And it went right down your throat.
-I coughed, like, 30 pieces up.
I don't know what I did. I don't know how I did that.
-I didn't know that was you.
-Oh, you thought it was a different --
-Yeah. -Thank you. Amazing.
No, I was just acting.
That was me in a wig acting as a film critic.
-Oh, my God! I was not aware of that!
-Well, there you go. -My gosh! Bravo!
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, listen to this.
Researchers say that an anti-hunger pill
is on the horizon that could replace the need for exercise.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
When they heard, Peloton was like,
"Okay, things can get worse. Alright."
Hey, I read about a bus driver
who was found passed out on the side of the highway,
and he said that he didn't know
that the gummies he was eating had THC in them.
[ Laughter ]
Even more upsetting, he's the most sober driver in the fleet.
And finally, guys, there's so many cool things to do
here in New York, and there's a brand-new
roller-skating attraction opening tonight
called the DiscOasis Central Park.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I had to check it out, so I called my pal Keke Palmer.
I said, "You wanna go skating in the park?"
She said, "Of course." So check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ] ♪♪
Hi, guys. Jimmy Fallon here.
I'm at the DiscOasis Central Park in New York City.
It is a roller rink.
It is a disco-immersive experience.
It is a party.
Right now, I'm going to put my
roller-skating skills to the test.
I'm going to get my skates on, and let's do this.
[ The Trammps' "Disco Inferno" plays ]
-♪ Burn, baby, burn ♪
♪ Burn, baby, burn ♪
-♪ Hey! ♪
[ Slow disco music playing ]
[ Music stops ]
[ Record scratches ]
-We're not doing the costumes?
-Unh-unh.
-Okay.
♪♪
-We're here with Khalil "Gifted" Johnson.
Thanks for having us.
You look great. Clearly, I don't.
What would you tell someone who's just learning
to roller-skate -- any advice?
-Always have a bend in your knees.
-Right? -A.k.a. balance.
-I feel like I'm at a good balance right now.
I feel like I can do this.
You're one of the expert roller skaters here,
and you're going to teach Keke and I a few moves
so that we'll be able to join your team
for a big performance later, right?
-Yes, sir. -Okay.
-So, it's a simple move, right? Shoot the duck.
-"Shoot the duck." That sounds like something cool.
-I'm gonna pick up that right leg.
-Alright. -Right?
And then drop down.
[ Laughs ]
-Squat down. -Uh-huh.
-We got this! -Yeah, he did! Yeah, he did!
-Whoo! -Yes. Yes.
-Ow! Ow!
What's the other move?
-Alright, now, now.
-So, your first step is going to be here.
-So we go...this?
-Yeah, yeah.
-This. -Yeah.
-Why do I look like this and you look like that?
-Let's crossover.
-Crossover? -Crossover.
Oh, that means I'm gonna die.
That's what that -- You can't say "crossover."
-Step.
Now we're going to put all your weight on the right side.
-This looks so -- I just saw --
I saw my shadow, and it's so embarrassing.
My shadow is embarrassing.
-Crossover. -1, 2.
-Yes, sir. -Crossover.
-Go back the other way. -1, 2.
1, 2.
-You hit that!
-Really? That was...
-Let's get it.
-Let's do it! -Let's do it.
-Let's do it. ♪♪
-Oh, now that's what I'm talking about.
♪♪
-♪ These are the good times ♪
-Whoo! Get it.
-♪ Leave your cares behind ♪
That's all -- Yeah, that's all I can really do.
So, what do you think? Are we ready to perform?
-I think you guys got it.
-Let's do this. -Let's do it, man.
♪♪
-Hold on. -I can't. I can't.
-I got you. I'll catch you.
-Pull me back. -He good, he good.
-And now the DiscOasis Dancers featuring Keke and Jimmy.
♪♪
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
[ Cheers and applause ] -We did it, guys!
-Yes! [ All cheering ]
We killed it! -You did it!
-Yes! Keke, take me home.
-Okay. Let's go.
[ The Trammps' "Disco Inferno" plays ]
♪ Burn, baby, burn ♪
-♪ Disco inferno ♪
-Oh, my thanks to Keke Palmer.
Go see her new movie, "Lightyear,"
in theaters this Friday.
I love Keke Palmer.
[ Cheers and applause ] She's the one.
And thank you to everyone at DiscOasis Central Park.
If you're in New York, go check it out.
It's now through the end of the summer.
We have a great show.